there is this idea that you can create
this fantasy of the life that you want
and sit at home and wait for it to come
true and do nothing about it the science
but also just my way of going about life
is that yeah create that dream that
ideal and and and do the collage and
have it somewhere in your house that you
look at it all the time and visualize it
becoming true
but also you have to go out there and do
things to make it come true you know if
you say oh I really want to get married
and have a baby well start looking after
your health and meeting suitable people
rather than going out partying all the
time if you think I really hate my job
but it pays the bills but I'd love to
you know go off and be a freelance
whatever ask yourself what you can
actually do about that